you know what i tried to do the other
day i looked at my son
and uh
i often tell my son i love you bud
i but i often say it like
do you know how much i love you you know
some [ __ ] like that do you know how much
dad dad loves you
and i was like you know what dude he's
two i'm gonna [ __ ] say it like a 40
year old
like a 40 year old telling another
[ __ ]
who's 40.
i love you
i'ma pull no punches
so i walk up to him
and i say hey calvin come here and he's
playing with like [ __ ] napkin holders
or some [ __ ] he's got 900 toys he's
playing with jingly napkin holders
and uh
uh you know or he's playing with that
[ __ ] little fish magnet game where
he's trying to do the fish but he's
getting real frustrated he can't do it
and then and then kristen told him to
just put it on the refrigerator and and
now it's just a magnet on the
refrigerator and she was like it's magic
and he now he's like um i'm like great
now he believes in it okay
good now he believes in [ __ ] magic
good
now he's gonna believe in magic dude you
know who also believes in magic me when
i turn on the shower i think my family's
gonna die in a plane crash
how about that that's magic so great now
we started ocd with calvin now [ __ ]
calvin's sitting there he's gonna be
like where are the portals mom when he's
eight
he's gonna believe in [ __ ] gizzards
and i say users because that's how he
says wizard
so uh he puts the [ __ ] magnet on the
thing and then she's like look magic
that look what i did magic and for the
first time he put the [ __ ] thing in
the refrigerator and he [ __ ] looked
at me like what do you think dude that
was cute as [ __ ] so i'm like i gonna
tell him i love him i'm gonna tell him i
love him like a 40 year old does another
40 year old he loves them
and so i look i look them in the eyes
and i said calvin i got to tell you man
i love you i love you i love you so much
do you know i love you so much i love
you so much and i love my job you know
how much dada loves his job when he goes
to work
and he said yeah and i said i love you
more
than that and it doesn't even compare
how much more that's how much i love you
i would give up anything for you i love
you that much i love you more than
anything in this world
and you know what he said
he looked at me right in eyes and he
said
i guess i need a raisin and walked away
is there anything
more like seriously think about it
any out of any age group is there
anything more
disrespectful to respond to to that
sentence
is there anything more disrespectful
to not even be first of all ray who the
[ __ ] eats raisins right whoever even
wants a raisin
raisins are [ __ ] horseshit you know
what i mean
every time i see raise it when's this
time you dude if you've eaten a raisin
in the last [ __ ]
i don't know 10 years
i mean i get i get it if you're just
like in the 90s eating raisins because
like you saw a [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] commercial where people are like
running around in fields with sunlight
peak you know what i mean i don't know
like what's that [ __ ]
raisin
seems like that would be a raisin
commercial but like there's no raisin
commercials now anymore you know don't
eat raisins
and so like i say i love you so much i
love you more than anything more than my
job which by the way is a step for me
cause i thought i had to like comedy
more than anything to be good at comedy
i thought that
up until
my family became what's important
i thought that stand-up was the goal
but it's not
[ __ ] all that [ __ ]
family right
so
now this is a step for me and i tell him
and i'm already like wow i'm making
progress in my life admitting to my
two-year-old that hey your dad
loves you more than anything
and this dude not only does he
want to ra he is not even sure he wants
the [ __ ] raisin that's how
disrespectful it is he's it would be
light years more respectful he was like
you know what i'm hungry for a raisin
but he was just [ __ ] dilly dallying
walking around saying i guess i need a
raisin
the most disrespectful anyone has ever
been to me and i made him
crazy
crazy
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
crazy
crazy
[Music]